the
series of
experts drives him crazy contact with
researchers investors experts
in entrepreneurship who can help
them get started in their project
milla diamond offers them financial assistance
so that you can have
all the resources to develop
your business
and then finally wanting doors of
knowledge you can develop
their innovations in a
cutting-edge research center as a mentor
for exercise programs and wings
I find that millas start-ups
add a very interesting scientific dimension
to the ecosystem by  galley they
are students who are curious who
are very strong scientifically and who
are thirsty to learn
[Music]
and
from milan
my marian identity came from the fact
that my partner and I had
common interests then through the
course in a  enabled us to
validate our company by presenting
our company in front of a jury for the
first time and then  resources
then helped us to propel our
business
it gives us the opportunity not
only to help
other common entrepreneurs who are
in the same stage of development but
also other
stakeholders in the
business system such as potential
investors the community
of entrepreneurs at the miller then amoriell
in general is really a great spirit of
cohesion so we really feel that we are
all together in the same boat when
we really try to see and everyone
be successful so everyone is
there to support you  pitt helped in
difficult times when the
greatest asset of the entrepreneurship lab
is that it is a program that has been
designed for research students
in ir as a program that
fits perfectly with their studies because
that  also allows students to
join a network of
current students graduate management
people all like common interests  of
the entrepreneur
[Music]